your thoughts about making peace of
conscious decisions but juxtaposed out
with a faculty your ethics system except
when you're about four or five I want
two things it seems very much from your
experience and I'm table might as well
set you encounter people and situations
that were not possible to understand
when you're for fri so there's a lot of
a lot of room as you go if you'd like to
deviate from it article value so you
have before or really reinforce what
you'd occurred previously and my
thoughts questions for you to speak more
to why you think that if you don't have
it by the time your for you'll never
have it because it seems like the
experiences and happy to go on I really
what formulate and make very clear to
you you know I have a yes it's the right
question in and my only answer which is
not probably not much of an answer is
that is at least I was raised in a way
that I knew I should balance my
interests with other people's interests
that wasn't as they did not necessarily
involve permanent and extraordinary
degrees of self-sacrifice maybe small
amounts of self-sacrifice but not huge
self-sacrifice it also on the other hand
didn't involve ignoring other people's
legitimate interests and so I grew up
with the idea that there should be a
reciprocity and fairness and dealing
with others and that one should serve
one's country now the fact is is that in
my case I stayed in college during the
Vietnam War which I thought was unfair
but I didn't have the strength to to
enlist I thought was unfair to people
who couldn't afford college but I you
know is it's very hard to be able to say
I'm going to do the right thing when it
involves sacrifice okay so I could avoid
certain situations I would avoid cuz I
knew that it would test me in ways then
my MOT where I might come up and fail
ethical tests I try to avoid the
situations because I knew I wasn't
strong enough but I knew at least
that one should that contrary to what
some people seem to think society does
exist we're not it's not just a question
of individuals and that you owe not only
the other as an individual but the other
society various loyalties and that that
may not be written in a pen and on a
stone we can find but it's written
somewhere did you see that those guys
have yourself a bad girl there he's dead
the only is it roll off I think EPP for
sure that's the only thing kept it going
for was that I strength to resist the
pressure from from Enron in the case of
spinnaker I think I think every single
employee improved as a person and
improved as a considered strictly as as
a capital asset their own capital asset
so we improve them people and we improve
their skill set because we were truly
interested in making sure that every
single person at eep eep not only DPP
but it's vinegar would be worth more to
themselves if we if the whole thing fell
apart I was worried with a startup that
you're going to have a situation where
it can always fail I was determined to
make sure that everyone who went there
would actually not only end up getting a
job but a better job as a result of
having been a spinnaker because of our
interest in improving them and it never
fell apart but that attitude was an
honest one and the employees knew that
it was an honest one and and if you get
the right people you can't get jaded
people if you get the right people they
will respond very well to that